WELCOME BACK.
I'M KRISTIE LU STOUT IN HONG
KONG.
RIGHT NOW, COMMUNIST CHINA'S
PARTY HAS JUST FINISHED
RESHUFFLING IT SENIOR
LEADERSHIP TO ALIGN LEADER XI
JINPING.
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST MANTAS
EVENTS AND MODERN CHINESE
HISTORY.
SERIOUS RAMIFICATIONS FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
THESE ARE THE SENIOR PARTIES OF
THE NEW STANDING COMMITTEE.
THEY'LL HOLD THE REINS OF POWER
AND SECURE MR. SHE'S POSITION
OF ABSOLUTE AUTHORITY IN CHINA.
MR. XI, IT MEANS AN A PRECEDENT
TO THIRD TERM, THE MOST
IMPORTANT POSITION.
--
MOST IMPORTANT RAISES SUCH AS,
COMMON PROSPERITY, FIGHTING
SPIRIT.
AND IT'S ADDED HIS FIERCE
OPPOSITION AS PART OF THE
PARTIES DOCTRINE.
LET'S GET SOME ANALYSIS NOW.
VICTOR SHE IS THE --
FROM NOW STRATAGEM TO THE RISE
OF SHE, A SOURCE A PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
SAN DIEGO.
HE JOINS US FROM SEATTLE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THE POPULAR STANDING COMMITTEE
IS, OF COURSE, THE APEX
APPARENT CHINA.
THEY HAVE JUST BEEN UNVEILED BY
XI JINPING.
YOU HAVE THE SHAM, THE PARTY
BOSS, HE'LL BE CHINA'S PARTY
BUS.
YOU HAVE THE BEIJING PRIEBUS.
THE CONDOM PRETTY SECRETARY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS LINEUP,
VECTOR?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
SO, REALLY, THIS HAS BEEN A
NORM BUSTING PRETTY CONGRESS
WHERE A NUMBER OF INTERNAL
NORMS IN THE PARTY HAS JUST
BEEN ABANDONED COMPLETELY.
EACH NORM EVENT BEING CLEAR
FORCED BEFORE THE AGE OF 68.
AND THEN, VERY LIKELY, YOU WILL
HAVE SOMEONE WITHOUT ANY STATE
COUNCIL EXPERIENCE SERVING AS
THE PREMIER OF CHINA.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED SINCE THE EARLY 19 80S
WITH THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
PREMIER CHINA.
THE CHINESE ECONOMY AND THE
STATE COUNCIL ITSELF ARE SO
MUCH MORE COMPLEX TODAY
COMPARED TO THE 19 80S.
I THINK NOT HAVING THAT
EXPERIENCE IS GOING TO MAKE IT
INITIALLY WHICHEVER FUN IN
CHINA'S STATE MACHINERY THAT
MUCH MORE CHALLENGING FOR THE
NEW PREMIERE CHINA.
>> THE SHOW TO THE NEXT PREMIER?
ELEVATED TO THE POLITBURO FOR
THE SYMBOLIC HANDLING OF THE
COVID IN SHANGHAI.
WHAT IS GOING ON THERE?
>> YEAH.
I DON'T THINK THAT NEEDS AN
EXPLANATION, SO TO SPEAK.
CHINA IS NOT A DEMOCRACY.
REALLY, AS WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE PROCEEDINGS AT
THE PARTY CONGRESS, ONLY ONE
MAN'S OPINION MATTERS.
WITH THIS NEW POLITBURO
STANDING COMMITTEE MEMBER, WE
SEE, FOR EXAMPLE, THE CHIEF OF
STAFF OR THE PRIVATE
SECRETARIES FROM THREE STAGES
OF XI JINPING'S CAREER.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT HE
SERVED AS A CLOSE ADVISER
TEACHING CAME FROM THERE IT IS
BACK AND FUJIAN PROVINCE.
THEN YOU HAVE THE SECRETARY IN
[INAUDIBLE] SO, THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HIM VERY WELL.
WHO HE TRUSTS A GREAT DEAL.
AND THEY ARE CHOSEN FOR THESE
TOP LEVEL POSITIONS BECAUSE OF
THAT.
YOU KNOW, REALLY, THEIR JOB
PERFORMANCE, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE INTERNATIONAL MEDIA THINK
OF IT, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
CHINESE PEOPLE THINK OF IT,
REALLY, IT'S QUITE SECONDARY
HERE.
>> I ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
WOMEN IN THE PARTY ELITE.
YESTERDAY, HE TWEETED VICTOR
SAY, SOARING, ONLY 11 WOMEN
AFTER 200 COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSAD, ESPECIALLY FOR COMMUNIST
PARTY.
YOU COULD TABULATING.
THAT PAUL BUREAU, 24
PALLBEARERS AND NOT A SINGLE
WOMAN CONFIRMED.
WHAT DOES DISSOLVE THE SAFER
THE C PC?
>> YEAH.
NOW, I THINK THIS IS REALLY
QUITE TRAGIC BECAUSE, OF COURSE,
WE KNOW A LOT A VERY CAPABLE
WOMEN IN CHINA.
EVEN IN THE PARTY, THERE ARE A
LOT A VERY CAPABLE WOMEN.
YET, AT EVERY LEVEL, THEY ARE
MARGINALIZED.
OCCASIONALLY, IF YOU WILL BREAK
THROUGH THE RANKS, SO TO SPEAK,
AND REST TO SIGNAL POSITIONS.
BUT THEY WERE MADE VERY, VERY
RARE.
TRADITIONALLY, AT LEAST SINCE
THE 1980S, THERE HAS BEEN ONE
WOMAN IN THE POLITBURO.
THIS TIME, YET AGAIN, WE DON'T
SEE ANY WOMEN AT THE POLITBURO
LEVEL.
I THINK THAT WILL HAVE SOME
LONG LASTING IMPACT ON GENDER
EQUALITY IN THE PARTY BECAUSE,,
A INADEQUATE TO HAVE THIS
EXAMPLE OF A WOMAN COMRADE
SENIOR BUBBLE.
AND ALSO, THERE'S NOT GOING TO
BE A FEMALE PATRON WHO KEPT
ASHLEY HELP SOME OF THE YOUNGER
WOMEN GET AHEAD IN THEIR
CAREERS.
SO, POTENTIALLY, WOMEN ARE
GOING TO BE MORE MARGINALIZED
IN THE PARTY.
>> SO MANY NORMS BEING BROKEN
WITH THIS PARTY CONGRESS.
LET'S LOOK AT SHIPPING HIMSELF.
XI JINPING HIMSELF TO BE PARTY
LEADER AGAIN.
THIS IS HISTORY MAKING.
WHAT COMES NEXT?
HOW SHE IS A POWER?
WHICH ISN'T MEAN FOR CHINA?
>> YEAH.
BY BREAKING THE TERM NORM THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED AFTER THE
TENEMENT SQUARE MASSACRE, I
THINK SHE JINPING IS SETTING
HIMSELF UP FOR A LIFETIME
TENURE.
THE SHORTER, OF COURSE, THERE
IS GREATER UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE
THERE IS NOT THE CONTESTATION
FOR WHO HOLDS THE TOP POSITION,
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOING TO BE
SHOOTING PINK AS LONG AS HE IS
ALIVE.
HOWEVER, OVER THE COMING YEARS
AS HIS HEALTH DETERIORATES, YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE HE'S A HUMAN
BEING AND WE ALL AGE, WE ALL
GET OLD.
YOU NOW, I THINK THAT SENSE OF
UNCERTAINTY IS GOING TO BUILD.
ALSO, GOING FORWARD, EVERY TIME
HE DISAPPEARS FROM PUBLIC VIEW
FOR LONGER THAN A WEEK OR TWO,
THERE'S GOING TO BE ALL KINDS
OF RUMORS.
IT COULD TRIGGER MAJOR SELL-OFF
IN THE MARKET.
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
REMEMBER, THIS CHINA'S THE
SECOND LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
THAT ACTUALLY HAS THE LARGEST
FINANCIAL SYSTEM BY BANKS AND
THE STOCK MARKET.
THIS ONE MAN AND THE ENTIRE
STABILITY AND PROSPERITY OF THE
COUNTRY IS DEPENDING ON 1%,
OVERTIME, IT'S GOING TO
GENERATE UNCERTAINTIES.
>> A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY WHEN
YOU HAVE SO MUCH POWER
CENTRALIZED OF ONE INDIVIDUAL.
TODAY, IT WAS ALL ABOUT YOU SHE
JINPING, FURTHER CONSOLIDATING
HIS POWER, PACKING THE SANDY
COMMITTEE MUSHY ALLIES.
WHAT ABOUT THE NEXT LEADER?
IS THERE ANY INDICATION, ANY
SIGNAL ABOUT SUCCESSION PLANS
FOR CHINESE LEADER AFTER SHE?
>> I DON'T REALLY SEE ANY SENSE
OF IT.
CERTAINLY NOT AT THE MEDIA
LEVEL, WHICH IS WHAT MOST OF US
HAD EXPECTED.
I THINK THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE MAKE IT TO SEE SOME HINT AT
THE 21ST PARTY CONGRESS,
POTENTIALLY NOT EVEN THEN.
I STILL HAVE TO LOOK CAREFULLY
THROUGH POPULACE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE YOUNG ENOUGH.
A FIRST GLANCE, IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE ANYONE WITHIN THE
POLITBURO IS NECESSARILY YOUNG
ENOUGH TO BE POTENTIAL
SUCCESSOR.
MEMBER, BASICALLY SOMEONE WHO
CAN BE A POTENTIAL SUCCESSOR IS
GOING TO BE H 47 OUR YOUNGER AT
THIS POINT.
WE DON'T SEE ANYONE LIKE THAT
IN THE RANKS.
>> WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
REMARKABLE MOMENT YESTERDAY
WHEN THE FORMER CHINESE
ALLITERATION TAO WAS LED OUT OF
THE HALL AS THE PARTY CONGRESS
CAME TO A CLOSE YOU SAW THAT
OFFICIAL EXPLANATION THOSE POST
ON TO WHAT ARE SAYING THAT IT
WAS HEALTH RELATED.
MANY OTHERS THINK IT'S A PAIR
OF PLAY.
OR XI JINPING FLAX.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT FOR
SYMBOLISM?
>> YEAH.
NOW.
I THINK IT WAS INDEED VERY
NOTABLE EVENT.
WE REALLY HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
DESTRUCTION TO THE PROCEEDINGS
LIKE THIS PRETTY MUCH EVER.
EVEN DURING THE CULTURE OF
LUCIAN.
THIS KIND OF THING HAPPEN.
CERTAINLY NOT WITH THE PARTY
CONGRESS.
I DON'T --
I'M NOT A LEAPER OF PURE HEALTH
EXPLANATION.
JUST BECAUSE THE LAST FORMAL
TASKS THAT WHICH INTEL
PERFORMED WAS TO VOTE FOR THE
NEW CENTRAL COMMITTEE, WHICH HE
DID MINUTES BEFORE THIS EVENT
TOOK PLACE.
IF HE HAD BEEN FEELING UNWELL,
THEY COULD HAVE DONE IT WITH
TIM AWAY FOR MEDICAL CARE.
YEAH, HE SAT DOWN.
HE HAD A SEAT, HE SAT DOWN IN A
PRETTY STABLE MANNER.
SUDDENLY, HE WAS ASKED TO
LEAVE.
REALLY, IT'S VERY PUZZLING.
HE WAS SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO
JINPING.
SO, I'M NOT SURE IF HE WHISPERS
SOMETHING, SAYS SOMETHING TO
SHE JINPING THAT TRIGGERED THIS
WHOLE CHAIN OF EVENTS OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
REALLY, IT'S A VERY NOTEWORTHY
EVENT AF